[Music]
get done that's the beginning of by
outward turning sperm and she done is my
in return
look how the art because why
comes back yeah
yawn this guy shoot up see that
difference
there is
then it starts to be that word for
example
[Music]
or yesterday's technique right
so hip an arm the arm goes up not by the
shoulder but by that kinda hit been arm
it keeps reversing between the two scars
olena so here I have Joe Don right at
$70
bringing it in get the cross level check
you to get on well then it comes up so
watch this body
oh nothing you actually stopping him
from coming in that's why I can push him
out this one see how you move okay so I
timed that T is the energy the energy so
I take it it was easily there okay so
there I now if I go straight I
disconnect because I moved him so I want
to go around which is what I want want
to start a circle oh that's the actual
movie you see
my future
[Music]
this is stopping him I'm on the side in
there and now you're gonna pull it young
on y'all's ass or whoa and he will just
fall back on that stage doing that this
also is your coiling strong strong
this is my internal flow and energy
conditioning okay then you put it all
together right
let's look at some indicators where am I
notice that I am behind and maybe even a
little to the other side of the axis of
the circle okay this is where I stay
I stay here so the timing is with him I
only opened my base too low over my
Center when he goes down I am NOT
pulling him down I have entered in our
this year
[Music]
so some things that are wrong you're not
behind you see your axis of rotation
it's more into the turning radius he's
behind that means you're boning okay and
that is young too young
[Music]
this is why you make these mistakes see
that hand if you need to bring him and
catch up to you and you have all these
little tricks but are you doing it is it
[Music]
that means you're checking and it's not
just me it's actually going this way so
if he has a knife you're actually
pulling the knife into you this hand is
guarding you see that outward
maintaining the integrity of the radius
not subverting
[Music]
holding the collar what if the guy
doesn't wear a dogie out in the street
is this a t-shirt guess what's gonna
happen
you're gonna have to start all over
don't be clothes dependent I'm back here
right there so stop doing EVP not yet
and just work on this puzzle drill
[Music]
anything you're bullying requires you to
be stronger than what you're moving that
means your performance ceiling is going
down
[Music]
let's go see now you're in the ballpark
to maybe try to get this part so the
last demonstrations were just to show
you that it doesn't take much
[Music]
so with that not much I'm going to do
something I can't just use that not much
okay because what I don't want is I
don't want you to tilt I don't want it
to tilt like this then you got to have a
choreography where he comes up perfectly
and walks into you're not good okay if
the guy felt it to that degree
you just keep his head down don't don't
let it come back that would be
ridiculous okay so I get to where he's
very much off-balance you see and I
compressed you see that oh I'll go slow
I can feel it and I start dropping
weight in the air okay you're less
sensitive your kids might not kick out
it just just but you will feel the
compression Oh
there it is right there compressed down
[Music]
low back in the right word you start to
feel it so you can't do it here
take that easiness and then start to
compress down boom now okay
try just that drill play okay so I'm
trying to stop this teeter-totter you
see that
[Music]
if you watch the teeter-tottering again
look at the angle of this bottom looks
like it works it's not Aikido those
because it's young on younger and it's
not marginally viable it's dependent
upon the caller right it says that he's
not going to come in for a single leg or
double leg all kinds of crops so my gig
here I get that tilt and I start to
compress into his spine you see that
and just like Yoda and if you feel
that's taking too much strength that's
where you started to turn you see and
now he's not falling although the ends
similar is trajectories not the same Oh
[Music]
slight tilt down you see
this will keep me behind him
oh you see not over here not over here
and keep on him though he can't he has
to do a turn to get his takedowns you
see that this is where I want to be
[Music]
slight tilt down and I starts moving it
out by tilt down full blue light till
now
[Music]
okay
and like to watch this hem okay slight
tilt start to compress the spine turning
this and don't let him keep the Garter
[Music]
like those compress this one you see out
Oh
all of that I'm doing : tilt compressed
Barbossa he can't he can't turn when I'm
doing this you see that you can't turn
and do take definitely okay as his head
ease it down
so he started to pick it up and when you
picked it up that's when I take his top
[Music]
I don't babies head up get in the right
place
there's the tilt there's the compressed
dance he gets up and I start to take his
balance so we're just working I don't
care about the last row just working on
the Kazushi timing tilt compress the
spine boom he gets up that's all I want
I'm not pulling him I think it's up I'm
guiding his ascent you understand tilt
compressed up he goes whoa
if you pay attention to my grip it's not
tightening around his neck
[Music]
okay you don't need that but bring it in
place for the other arm gel to compress
oh here it goes Oh onto my shoulder you
think okay but don't pull him don't rob
him
a guy misses them okay so if the neck
down of the second Kazushi is pushing
pulling grabbing it's because my my is
mom I'm too close I'm too far too early
I'm too late okay I think I'm stuck I
have a job to do them I have to take
this Center as that final position is
the tilt we just didn't get there that
way you get it I have to make his head
and his foot go around his Center I
can't just pull up on his head so it'll
just be down I can't just pull up on his
head I have to make his body rotate
around his center of gravity he gets up
think the foot goes back forward that
means he's going to already be falling
then I just aim a falling person comes
up
they can't just do it any old way
[Music]
so default and I named that
okay so try to get that understand what
you're doing with his extremities and
your center of gravity it's the same
thing you're doing on every back break
ball